la droite conserve finalement ce canton
le trap arrivé deuxième au premier tour
des élections départementales
le binôme sortant nicolas dainville and
capio conserve les deux sièges au
département des yvelines
ce dimanche 27 juin le duo totalise
52,17 % des suffrages
c'est ce point de plus qu'au premier
tour il devance le duo divers gauche aly
rabé al-marri a bookish c'est la
victoire d'une campagne qui a été un peu
difficile avec nos amis d'à côté de
trappes
il a fallu qu'on se bat qu'on fasse
beaucoup beaucoup de terrain il a fallu
qu'on réveille un peu notre électorat
pour le deuxième tour on a réussi et on
est très content très heureux très
heureux de ce travail en équipe parce
que c'est vraiment grâce à toute
l'équipe de nos trois communes qu'on a
pu gagner ce soir l'équipe de trappes
l'équipe de la verrière l'équipe
d'elancourt qui se sont mobilisés parce
qu'ils ont cru en notre projet ils ont
cru en nos valeurs
ils ont cru renens notre volonté
d'améliorer les choses sur ces beaux
canton en tête au premier tour les
candidats de la gauche aly rabais and
mary bouquet termine finalement à cette
deuxième place avec 47 2 83%
malgré une progression de plus de 1400
voix entre les deux tours
ce n'est pas suffisant pour espérer
reprendre le canton après l'avoir perdue
en 2015
mais le binôme échoué perles canton avec
500 voix d'écart et un score de 69 57%
dans la ville de trappes
je voudrais féliciter mes adversaires
qui ont réussi à remporter à maintenir
leur canton la bataille a été rude
ils vont gagner plus largement lors de
la dernière élection ça a été très
serrée cette fois je ne doute pas que la
prochaine sera en faveur de la gauche et
qu'on l'a remporteront et je voudrais
également dire que je suis
particulièrement fier et honoré de la
confiance que m'ont témoignée
personnellement les trappistes en votant
à près de 70% pour leur mère
au terme d'un an seulement deux mandats
la participation sur l'ensemble du
canton est quant à elle en eau sur ce
second tour avec 29 points 30% et un
être bon attraper avec 27 26%
près de six points de plus qu'au premier
tour